hi this is lattice inspired broadcast
encryption 16 ciphertext policy abe i'm
sevika barkerski and this is joint work
review notebyquintanathan
let's start by talking about broadcast
encryption we consider a content
provider that wishes to provide content
for multiple users so we have capital
end users that want to consume content
however not all content is intended for
all users so the provider wishes to
encrypt the content such that only
authorized users can decrypt the
specific content
we associate each user with a secret key
and the encryption is done with respect
to an authorized set s such that
only if user x is inside the set s
its secret key s k sub x is should be
useful in order to decrypt the
ciphertext ciphertext of s
and an important security property that
we require is resilience for collusions
so even if some users come together if
none of these users individually is
inside the set s and is not supposed to
be able to decrypt the ciphertext
even if they come together and use all
of their ciphers or all their secret
keys together they should still not have
any advantage in decrypting the
ciphertext
now the property that we wish to
optimize on is the length of the secret
key so we the length sorry of the
ciphertext we want the ciphertext to be
as short as possible
indeed the naive solution is to just
encrypt the content uh individually for
each user so just encrypt end times with
respect to each secret key
and this indeed has the required
functionality
but um we would like to do better so we
consider a setting where the set itself
the um the set itself does not need to
be incorporated in the ciphertext so we
assume that the set is actually known to
the users and of course the provider and
the question is what is the additional
ciphertext that we need to that we need
to send in order to send our content and
we could hope to that the length of the
cipher text is um
almost independent
of the
number of users so maybe only
the relation is only poly logarithmic
so what is known about this problem
it depends on the cryptographic
assumption that you're willing to make
so if we make assumptions that are
related to the hardest discrete log
problem in groups that have a bilinear
map between them
this is a family of cryptographic
assumptions then we can have a
polynomial improvement over the naive
solution so we can do a square root or
cube root of n
as the length of the ciphertext and you
can even also get an optimal solution in
an amortized setting where you first
send like some chunk of length n and
then you don't need to pay much for each
additional information that you're
sending so this is what is known in the
bilinear setting
now if in addition to linear assumptions
you also use lattice
assumptions or specifically the learning
with errors problem then you can
come up with some non a non-standard set
of assumptions under which you get
optimal um performance so polylogin
dependence on the number of users um and
this is uh this is a sequence of works
from fairly recently
you can also get optimal ciphertext
length by relying on obfuscation or
related or related assumptions
it is still open problem whether it's
possible to get optimal parameters by
just relying on lattice assumptions and
in particular the learning with errors
problem so the learning with errors
problem is a notable example of a family
of lattice assumptions which are very
useful in cryptography and in particular
they they it has been discovered at
least especially in recent years that
they have favorable features both in
terms of functionality allowing us to
get
to achieve cryptographic primitives that
we don't know how to achieve under
different assumptions and also in terms
of security since as far as we know
these problems are largely resilient to
quantum attacks so um
we
in the community we're able to construct
many advanced cryptographic primitives
from
these kinds of assumptions and actually
broadcast encryption is possibly the
last advanced cryptographic primitive
standing that we did not know how to
achieve uh from from these from these
assumptions
so it's an interesting open problem
whether we can sort of close this gap
and you can try to go one step further
and consider an extension of the problem
known as ciphertext policy
attribute-based encryption so i'm going
to quickly explain what it is
so remember though we talked about
broadcast encryption we consider an
authorized set of users however we can
just consider an authorized policy of
users so we can consider a function that
takes its input the identity of the user
x and it
its output actually dictates whether
this user is allowed or not allowed to
decrypt the ciphertext so in the context
of ciphertext policy abe
when you have um a secret key that's
associated with user x and a ciphertext
that's associated with functionality f
then if f of x equals to one then the
secret key is supposed to be able to
decrypt and recover the content
and if not then it should not be able to
learn anything and again the same
collusion resilience property is
required required to hold so
we would like to know whether it's
possible to create ciphertext policy abe
where the ciphertext does not scale much
with
the circuit that computes the the
authorized policy so this is the
extension that we are thinking about and
actually throughout the talk i'm just
going to talk about the the two problems
broadcast encryption and cpab
interchangeably so i'm going to use the
letter f but if you're more comfortable
when thinking about rocket's encryption
you can always sort of replace my f with
capital s and just think about sense
so what do we do in this work um
unfortunately we don't uh we don't solve
this problem we
this this problem is still open even
after our our work however we do present
a candidate which is inspired by lattice
assumptions
and actually achieves broadcast
encryption and ciphertext policy abe
with optimal parameters so yeah we don't
solve we don't solve this open problem
and um
what we have going for our for our
construction is that uh so far we don't
know of any attacks so we we've been
trying for for quite a long time to
either find attacks or to find um
a security proof for for um our uh
construction and we were able to do
neither so um there's no known attacks
and we don't also we also don't have a
proof of security based on
lattice assumptions on these
cryptographic assumptions and even more
annoyingly we don't even have a closed
form assumption so we could say well we
don't know how to prove based on the
learning with errors problem but here's
an assumption which is not just assuming
that the scheme is secure uh just uh for
based on the definition of broadcast
encryption but coming up with uh an
assumption that does not uh directly
relate to the security game of broadcast
encryption and still allows us to um
to show a security proof so this is this
would be useful for example for trying
to break or prove uh the hardness of our
uh the security of our scheme and we
were not able to do this so this is
another sort of shortcoming of our
result but sort of a challenge to the
community i guess
um we can sort of explain why the
obvious attacks that we know uh from
from uh similar similar context uh fail
in this case but that's more or less
that's more or less it um
so
yeah um our our hope though is that
because our construction is lattice
inspired in the sense that we use the
building blocks and methods uh that are
used in lattice base or learning with
errors based cryptography then this
should make it uh somehow approachable
uh to either come up with a proof or
come up with an attack even though we
were not able to do this so this is like
uh we're sending this to the community
in hope for for help
yeah so um hopefully um this is just a
starting point for for more advances
so how do we do this um our starting
point is another version of this
attribute-based encryption thing that i
was talking about before but this time
it's going to be sort of reversed so
it's a succinct attribute encryption
scheme but instead of being ciphertext
policy this scheme is key policy what
does it mean so remember that before we
said that we have cipher text that are
associated with some sets or some
functions and we have secret keys that
are associated with
inputs or users x so now actually the
cipher text in the key policy abe
i'm going to denote it by key policy
ciphertext and key pause the secret key
so a key policy ciphertext is associated
with an input x and the key policy
secret key is associated with the
function f and the condition for
decryption is the same as before if f of
x equals to 1 then the secret key
is is supposed to be able to decrypt the
ciphertext
and the crucial point here is that this
kpib scheme by bonair
is actually succinct in the same in the
same sense that we want the parameters
of the scheme do not scale with the
circuit size
of the function f
so um this is sort of going to be our
starting point and our goal is going to
be to sort of flip things around and get
a ciphertext policy abe scheme with uh
while preserving the succinctness
property
so let's see
we're going to actually use the
individual properties specific
properties of this key policy abe scheme
and let's in particular see how
we encrypt cipher text in this scheme so
now ciphertexts are associated with
inputs x
so the input x has
n bits so it's an n-bit input
and what we the the first but the first
step in the encryption is actually
oblivious of x so we just create two n
ciphertext pieces uh so at this point we
don't i don't even need to know what x
is i just create these two times n
pieces so n pairs of pieces of
ciphertext you can think about them as
matrices actually they are going to be
matrices
and then in the second step after
we sort of generate these pieces we
select
one out of each pair of pieces and the
selection is done according to the bits
of x so the first bit of x is zero so
i'm going to select the first piece out
of the first pair the second bit of x is
one so i'm going to select the second
piece out of the second pair and so on
and so forth
and um we take these end pieces that we
that we selected so one out of each pair
and combine them into a matrix and this
matrix is the key policy cipher text so
there's this two-phase process for
constructing the ciphertext and this is
going to be useful for us
now how do we decrypt
so
we have our decryption key and this is
going to be a vector
so this is the secret key and it's
associated with a function f
and decryption process um
includes a derivation step where we
start with our secret key and derive
from it using the um
the input x so now i i'm getting um the
secret key for f and the ciphertext for
s x and i want to decrypt so at this
point i know x so i'm using my x to
derive from my secret key uh a longer
vector so um
there's this derivation process that
allows me to take my secret key and
which is a vector itself and derive a
longer vector from it and then we just
multiply this vector on the right with
uh with the ciphertext and this is
essentially we do a little bit more
stuff but this is the essential part of
the decryption process so these are the
properties of this key policy abe scheme
and now let's see how to use it to our
advantage
so
um
what do we do how do we try to sort of
like put this thing on its head and get
a ciphertext policy scheme
so um
let's see so remember we have a key
policy secret key that depends on f and
the key policy ciphertext depends on x
and you want to do the other way around
so now we want a ciphertext that depends
on f
so our ciphertext is going to start by
just sort of generating a key policy
secret key for f and just putting it as
a part of the cipher text so the
ciphertext is going to include this
secret key
which is sort of specialized for f
in addition i'm going to take this this
part of the encryption that is
independent of x remember now at this
point when i'm encrypting with respect
to f i know f but i don't know anything
about x so i can perform the first phase
of the encryption of the key policy
scheme uh but i cannot perform the
second phase of the selection so i'm
just going to sort of defer the second
step to the decryption type to
decryption time so i'm generating i'm
generating all these two times end
pieces
and i'm going just going to lock each
one of them with an individual lock
such that
the idea is that in the secret key i'm
going to give the user the information
to unlock
only the boxes that correspond
that are associated with its identity x
such that you should be able to only
unlock one out of two um
one out of two uh pieces from each pair
but we have to do it in a way that
maintains the collusion resilience so if
we have two different secret keys and
each one of them can
unlock like a different uh
subset of the pairs we still need to be
able to argue that
an adversary that has multiple secret
keys that none of which is allowed to
recover um is allowed to properly
decrypt then this property is still
going to be maintained
even you know in this with with this
procedure
uh so
um in particular the property that we
require is stronger so not only that the
secret key of x will allow us to unlock
one out of each element one element out
of each pair but rather the unlocking
process is going to recover something
that looks like a fresh key policy
ciphertext for x so that if you're
actually not authorized to decrypt
then with your secret key you should be
able to recover many things that look
like key policy cipher text with respect
to different access that none of which
is allowed to uh be decrypted by uh you
know the key policy secret key of f so
it's as if
uh the situation that we want to create
is as if you received a bunch of
ciphertext a bunch of key policy cipher
text
where none of which is decryptable using
the key policy secret key that you have
so you should not be able to learn
anything so this is sort of the
intuition of what we want to do so we
want to design our locking mechanism
such that it is possible to unlock
one element out of each pair in a way
that does not reveal too much
information
so let's talk a little bit more about
the locking mechanism in order to do
this
i should like mention an additional
property of the key policy scheme so i
said that in order to decrypt um we
multiply we generate this longer vector
and multiply on the right but i didn't
say what happens when you multiply this
key policy matrix on the left
so um i should say sort of
uh that
more or less without getting into like
into subtle points when you multiply on
the left you sort of re-randomize the
cipher deck so multiplying the
ciphertext on the left
by sort of something that comes from the
proper distribution
sort of randomizes it it randomizes some
parts of this of the ciphertext and this
is something that we're going to use
okay so how do we block and unlock
ciphertext pieces
so the lock is going to be very simple
i'm just going to take the ciphertext
piece and add a mask to it so
each
ciphertext piece is associated with like
an index i and a big b so whether it's
the zero or one element of the ith pair
that we generated and for each one of
these elements we're going to
add a mask
now these masks are by themselves going
to be ciphertext for an encryption
scheme but think about this encryption
team as having transposed properties
compared to the original encryption
scheme that we started from in the sense
that it's decrypted by multiplying on
the left so the secret keys for this new
schema are still going to be for the
mask scene are still going to be vectors
but rather than multiplying on the right
we multiply on the left
so
for every x we can actually generate a
secret key that we call that we denote
by t sub x here such that um for all you
know if we look at the mask sub i comma
x i so if for the mass that sort of
correspond to the bits of uh of this uh
identity x if you multi if we take tx
and multiply it by the mask on the left
then we get something that's
approximately zero so it's so t sub x we
have a vector
that essentially annihilates all the
masks that correspond to the bits of uh
to the bits of x
and you know obviously this is the
functionality but all the other masks
all the masks that do not correspond to
the bits of x
remains to the random even uh when i'm
giving you the um the the ski t of x the
left hand multiplying uh secret key t of
x
so um given a scheme of this sword like
a transpose scheme what do we do
well in order to unlock
in order to unlock
a ciphertext piece we just multiply it
on the left by t sub x so t sub x is
just going to be our the secret key of x
and in order to unlock the pieces we
multiply on the left and since
multiplying on the left sort of
annihilates the mask what we get is that
when you take a locked piece and
multiply it on the left um sort of in in
a location where it's authorized you are
you're going to get a multiplication of
t sub x on the left
with the actual the unlocked uh
ciphertext piece
and this should indeed allow you to
combine all the pieces that correspond
to x together and obtain a key policy
the key policy cipher text of x
multiplied on the left
by this
key t sub x
and as we said
in the previous slide
multiplying on the left sort of
randomizes uh the the ciphertext so if
you do it for multiple uh t sub x's then
you get ciphertext that sort of look
sort of uh uh random
and this is sort of our hope this is
what we are hoping to bank on so our
hope is that even an adversary that's
colluding so remember a colluding
adversary is going to have a bunch of t
sub x's
but none of them corresponds uh none of
them correspond to xs for which um for
which the key policy secret key is
supposed to be able to decrypt
so it's possible to use each one of
these um each one of these d sub x's uh
to um um to unlock and recover uh a key
policy cipher text so um um it is
possible that we can uh
uh sort of unlock
even all the mass so assume that we have
the t t for the all zeros and t for the
old ones then each one of the pieces can
be unlocked by one of these uh by one of
these keys but it's going to get
multiplied on the left by the different
by different randomizer so it's not
going to allow you to sort of combine
them together and obtain key policy
cipher texts for um x's that you're uh
for x's that um are going to be
decryptable so even a colluded adversary
should hopefully you know this is this
is our security hope should not be able
to recover
um to recover ciphertext that it can use
the key policy um the key policy key
secret key
to decrypt
so um we should now be able to sort of
put together uh these uh sort of
different ciphertext different key
policies ciphertext for different x's in
order to um sort of get a key policy
ciphertext for something that is
decryptable
and um yeah so this is sort of all we
have and the question is now whether
it's possible to prove this where it's
possible to attack it whether it's
possible to sort of um
like put together some uh hardness
assumption that captures uh this uh
intuition on on why things need to be
secure and
you know we're hoping that
down the line someone is going to be
able to do it so this is all i have
right now thank you very much